TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
PEOPLE MAY NOT LIKE
WASHINGTON OR NATIONAL
POLITICS BUT THERE ARE SOME
VERY POPULAR GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DELIVERING RESULTS FOR THEIR
STATES.
WE KICKED OFF A NEW SERIES
WITH GOVERNORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, TONIGHT WE ARE
PLEASED TO WELCOME ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR ASA HUTCHINSON, HE
IS ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
GOVERNORS IN COUNTRY HAVING
WON -- REELECTION.
HE ATTRACTS GOOD JOBS AND
NEW RESIDENTS AND DEVOTED
TIME AND RESOURCES TO
IMPROVING THE STATE A
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
>> JOINING US NOW ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR ASA HUTCHINSON,
THANK YOU GOVERNOR FOR
JOINING US ON A SUNDAY
NIGHT, TELL US ABOUT WHAT
GOOD THINGS IN THE GREAT
STATE OF ARKANSAS.
>> THANK YOU, TREY, GOOD TO
BE WITH YOU, APPRECIATE YOUR
SHOW AND YOUR SERVICE IN
CONGRESS.
YOU ARE RIGHT I'VE SERVED IN
CONGRESS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT THERE IS
NOT A BETTER JOB OF LEADING
THE STATE LIKE ARKANSAS,
HERE IN THIS STATE WE
LOWERED TAXES WHEN I CAME IN
TO OFFICE WE HAD 7%
INDIVIDUAL INCOME TAX RATE.
THAT HAS BEEN LOWER TO 4.9
PERCENT.
WE HAD ZERO DOLLARS IN OUR
RESERVE ACCOUNTS, NOW WE
HAVE OVER 1.2 BILLION
DOLLARS IN RESERVE.
YOU MENTIONED EDUCATION,
THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
I SAID 8 YEARS AGO I WANTED
TO PUT COMPUTER SCIENCE IN
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL IN
ARKANSAS, WE DID THAT WE
BECAME A NATIONAL LEADER, WE
WENT FROM 1100 STUDENTS TAKE
COMPUTER SCIENCE TO OVER
12500 AND SHRUNK THE SIZE OF
GOVERNMENT, MY GOAL TO GROW
THE PRIVATE SECTOR OF OUR
ECONOMY MORE THAN
GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE REDUCED BY 14% OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES WE'RE PAYING
THEM MORE WE ARE UTILIZING
TECHNOLOGY TO DELIVER
SERVICES.
AND BECAUSE OF ALL, THAT WE
-- THIS WEEK WE HAD
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM TYSON SOME
HEADQUARTER JOB FROM
ILLINOIS ARE MOVING BACK TO
ARKANSAS, THIS IS GREAT NEWS
FOR US, OUR ECONOMY IS
GROWING.
WE -- WE'RE DELIGHTED WITH
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE.
TREY: YOU ARE MODEST IN YOUR
RESUME, YOU WERE U.S.
ATTORNEY, AND DEA
ADMINISTRATOR,
WHAT IS THE MAIN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SERVING IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
YOU HAVE DONE BOTH.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, YOU
ARE DEALING WITH ISSUES THAT
THEY IMPACT EVERYONE'S LIVES
WHETHER YOU ARE IN
WASHINGTON OR HERE.
BUT THEY CAN CALL YOU UP
HERE, THEY KNOW YOU.
AND SO THAT IS WHAT IS NICE,
IT IS MORE PERSONAL IN THE
STATE, BUT YOU ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO GET THINGS
DONE, NOT ENOUGH TO KICK IT
DOWN THE ROAD, WE MENTIONED
SOME OF OUR SUCCESS STORIES,
BUT YOU KNOW OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN, WE HAD OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN PROGRAM AND CRISIS
WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH FOSTER
PARENTS, I CREATED A TASK
FORCE THAT WORKED ON THIS
AND IMPROVED OUR FOSTER
CARE.
AND START A REENTRY PROGRAM
TO HELP THOSE WANTS TO
SECOND CHANCE COMING OUT OF
PRISON.
THESE ARE JUST SIMPLE
PROBLEMS THAT YOU ARE HAVING
TO ADDRESS AND HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU WORK ACROSS THE AISLE,
MAIN OF OUR PROPOSAL GET
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT, YOU ARE ABLE TO
WORK AS A TEAM MORE LOOKING
AT WHAT IS BEST FOR OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
AND SO THERE ARE STILL
PARTISAN DIVIDE, OBVIOUSLY,
WHEN YOU COME ACROSS THE
PANDEMIC WE KEPT OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN AND KEPT OUR BUSINESSES
OPEN.
AND THAT WAS A DIFFERENCE IN
LEADERSHIP AMONG BLUE STATES
AND RED STATES, PROUD OF
WHAT WE DID HERE IN THIS
STATE OF ARKANSAS AND
KEEPING EVERYTHING OPEN.
TREY: GOVERNOR, ARKANSAS I
BELIEVE HAS TERM LIMITS, YOU
ARE NOT RUNNING FOR
REELECTION.
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT RUN FOR
REELECTION, YOU ARE TERM
LIMITED.
IS THERE ANY JOB OUT THERE
THAT WOULD ENTICE YOU WANT
TO STAY IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE HAVE TWO 4-YEAR TERMS, I
END IN JANUARY, I HAVE A LOT
TO DO BETWEEN NOW AND THEN,
FINISHING STRONG.
BUT, WHENEVER BEEN INVOLVED
IN PUBLIC SERVICE, AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SEEING THE
IMPACT OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
WASHINGTON ON OUR LIVES, YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE, I LOOK FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY, YOU ASK ABOUT
ONLY ONE JOB THAT WOULD TEMP
ME TO PUBLIC SERVICE THAT IS
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE.
THE CRYING NEED IN OUR
COUNTRY FOR LEADERSHIP, FOR
CHANGE OF OUR ENERGY POLICY,
TO GET A HANDLE ON INFLATION
AND TO HAVE THE RESPECT
ACROSS THE GLOBE FOR RONALD
REAGAN'S STRONG AND
FREE AMERICA, THAT IS WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE, WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN JANUARY.
TREY: GOVERNOR, I
NOTICE YOU WENT TO
COLLEGE IN SOUTH CAROLINA,
IF YOU RETIRE, I BELIEVE
THAT BEACHES IN SOUTH
CAROLINA MAY BE BETTER THAN
BEACHES IN ARKANSAS WE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE YOU BACK IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> I'LL BE THERE, I KNOW
WHAT SPARTANBERG, I WENT TO
SCHOOL IN GREENVILLE, I'LL
GO BACK THERE, WHAT A GREAT
STATE.
AND I HAD A COMPUTER SCIENCE
CONFERENCE THERE THAT THEY
ARE DOING WELL IN, I WANTED
TO BRAG ON ON THEM.
TREY: GREAT, NEXT TIME ARE
HERE, LET ME KNOW, I'LL TAKE
YOU TO PLAY GOLF, THANK YO